MAN: Whoever it is you
are, whatever it is you
want, I can get it for you.
I know this isn't personal.
It's just business.
Try to negotiate
with me again and I'll
have your tongue cut out.
WOMAN: Since we brought him in
off the Andrew Hall kidnapping,
he's given up a total of 23 safe
houses all over the Caucasus.
We will waste a month
looking into that many.
Desiree is the only one
that can narrow down
the operational window quickly.
I need you to
help me ID someone.
I'm not doing anything
until I talk with my family.
I will arrange a call
after you ID this man.
You can trust me.
Do you know him?
No.
Well, that's not bad.
Try an autumn filter on that.
Pictures are good, man.
They help us remember.
There's only one
kill I have I don't
need a picture to remember.
Yeah, which one?
My first.
I remember every line
on the guy's face.
Last time I ever saw my dad.
I'm sorry to just
drop on like this, OK?
But I've been thinking
and you were right.
I hadn't been thinking
what it was like to be you.
Who's that?
WOMAN: Mason, he's my teacher.
You sleeping with this guy?
Joe!
Stay away from my wife!
This is not how we
get back together.
Andrew Hall and
two of his assistants
were grabbed by the [inaudible]
movement in Baku, Azerbaijan.
For those of you who
failed geography,
Baku is North of
Iran, South of Russia.
So don't start World War III.
Look, Amanda Rankins
is a good officer,
but I do things differently, hm?
So let's skip the bull [muted].
I know who you are,
you know who I am.
Now load out.
Wheels up three hours, boys.
[interposing voices]
I need you to find out
who our new prisoner is.
I told you, I don't know him.
Michael?
We thought you were dead!
WOMAN: We need to know
what he knows about Hall,
where he might be kept.
Can't do that.
You know.
Find out where they took him.
If you're going to own me,
make it look like you want me.
MAN: I want you
to put everything
you're feeling into the mask.
The biggest obstacle
to full recovery
is that we struggled
to hang on to who
we were before the injury.
Come on, man.
It's OK to let go
of that person,
to embrace who we are now.
It's worked for countless
others and it's mandatory.
That sucked.
Want to get a drink?
Nope, I want to get several.
Nice.
Andrew Hall.
Who?
Don't tell her anything.
Shut up.
[groan]
MAN: Before this happened,
I never thought or believed
that this could happen to me.
Invincible, right?
Every time I'd go
through a door,
I'd be worried
about my brothers,
making sure they got home
safe, having their backs.
So what I'm afraid of
is that the next time
I walk through that door
that I'm worried about me
and not them, and that's
how guys end up dead.
What if you woke
up one morning
and you couldn't do that job?
There's no guarantee
you'll ever gain
the mobility and
dexterity in your hand
to return to your team.
No, this is bull
[muted] is what it is.
It's bull [muted].
VLADIMIR: Tell him we're
taking him to the mountains
to [inaudible].
It means they're
going by water.
[inaudible]
VLADIMIR: What have you done?
What I had to do.
You betrayed us!
I kill you!
I don't need to speak to
anybody in this room about who
we're going after here.
Nasry, he made us bleed,
but this guy, the prince--
this is the head of the snake.
Capture or kill.
We're going to in
fill at high tide.
Fish, you're going
to peel off once we
get boots on the ground, set up
an overwatch on the south side.
Overwatch is set.
COMMANDER: We'll
reach our set point.
We will wait for Golf to breach
their primary entry point.
[inaudible] one, set.
SOLDIER (RADIO): Golf, execute.
Delta, execute.
Once we have the hostages,
we'll get back in the boats.
We're gone.
SOLDIER: Grenade!
SOLDIER (RADIO): Anyone got
eyes on Hall or his aide?
Negative.
No Hall, no Adams.
Mom!
You put a tracking
app on my phone?
It's for your own good.
I'm Annabell.
You don't trust me?
No, it's not that.
I just-- I don't know
who your friends are.
Chloe.
[knocking]
MAN: Don!
WOMAN: Tier one, I had a
plan, just a simple follow
through to right a wrong.
But just before I did the
deed, I closed my eyes.
And for the first time in
forever, I didn't see death.
I saw you.
I don't think I'm ready
for what that means
and I don't think
you are either.
So please don't
come looking for me.
Dawn out.
WOMAN: We didn't
find Andrew Hall.
Well, that's not my fault. I--
I got Vladimir to give up the
safe house because you told
me it would help my family.
You'd get me out of here.
That was the deal.
WOMAN: I know.
Then this came in.
No more games.
Give me Michael Nasry and I
will give you Andrew Hall.
You have 24 hours to begin
preparations for the exchange
before I start sending pieces
of Mr. Hall to the White House.
WOMAN: He wants me
at the exchange.
He's going to kill both of us.